in 2015 pole star became the official
performance division of Volvo cars the
collaboration with the Swedish automaker
actually goes back to 1996 when pole
star was founded under the name flash
engineering it's been Volvo's
Motorsports partner ever since now it
has designed the most powerful
production Mobile's
of all time the pole star branded s60
sedan and the v60 station wagon
back in 2009 Polestar began supplying
tuning and performance accessories for
road going Volvo's the new dynamic duo
boasts over 50 optimizations resulting
in 270 kilowatts of output and an
equipment package that translates into a
sports car for everyday driving
we checked out the s60 sedan powered by
a souped-up t6 gasoline engine and
all-wheel drive this Polestar production
model comes with plenty of Motorsports
caliber and provides the technical basis
for the current Volvo racing cars and
the FIA World Touring Car Championship
which Volvo returned to last year our
car reviewer Michelle Assenmacher finds
the s60 promising from the outside
thanks to its beefy looks our first
impression on the inside however is the
very opposite the center console with
its maze of buttons and knobs is not too
user-friendly the interior features pole
stars stylish blue stitching among the
other nice features a heated steering
wheel and carbon fiber inlays adorning
the dashboard and center console
the sports seats with their new buck and
nappa leather upholstery provides solid
support for more aggressive driving
styles michelle admits she kind of fell
in love with the steering wheel that
combination of smooth leather and
alcantara gives the wheel far better
grip and a gorgeous feel the suspension
comes with shock absorbers that can be
adjusted and a variety of settings from
super comfortable to super hard ideal
for taking the car out on the racetrack
for example for everyday use the mid
range setting makes the most sense
the s60 also has the power to take on
the steepest of mountains in style
Michelle explains Michelle only found it
right to put the most powerful Volvo
ever through its paces on the Autobahn
as well even at high speeds she feels
that customary Volvo safety so for now
we have the mid-sized s and v60 editions
but Volvo intends to establish Polestar
as a performance brand for other
segments as well it will be interesting
to see which models bear the pole star
badge in the future
the show has to hand it to the s60
Polestar on one front it's a lot of fun
off the highway as well good
acceleration of these curvy country
roads and a tight turning circle testify
to the cars agility a pleasure to drive
all in all the Volvo s60 Polestar is a
sporty ride that's really fun to drive
all twist the net successfully on touch
me ohonta mystic v whatever lights it
prices for the s60 Polestar in germany
started 68,000 euros